you see some of him and her kids I see a
lot of him in Cameron actually Canon is
a very sweet sensitive soul and that's
how my brother was Kristin Cavallari
reflects on the death of her brother
Michael
she received the news just a few weeks
before Christmas are you doing okay you
know I mean I have good days and bad
days but I've really found a lot of
strength in my kids I mean I had sailor
at the same time my brother went missing
and then ultimately passed away and so
you know I was just I couldn't I
couldn't collapse I had a newborn baby
to look after I had to be strong for her
and for my whole family so that's what
I've been doing and has her family
holding up here okay everything here you
know I feel for my parents I you know
they've been going through it but
everyone's everyone's getting better
it's such a good heart um he was really
he was just a really good guy and you
know he we had a we had a fun he was the
only one who could push my buttons the
way it said you know I was like that
brother-sister relationship and we used
to always like he would make me laugh
and push my buttons and make me laugh
now Kristin has written a new book about
her life balancing in heels people think
that they know me coming from reality TV
obviously but they really don't and so
I'm excited to let people in you know
this is the first time I've really been
honest and real like this so I'm I'm
nervous but I'm excited